welcome back to appreciation Design This
is PJ in today's jury care tutorial I
would like to show you how to make this
pendant arrange the song Hello from the
back for this pendant design are you
ready let's get started
before we start making this pendant one
thing we need to keep in mind that the
Center Stone size might affect how many
Stone it's going to be around it so
depends on the size of a stone your
Arrangement might be different all right
that's starting from the scratch let's
bring in a stone and you can download
the stone file in the description below
to sign up with newsletter and then
you'll get a link for it once you have a
stone size into the size that you like
to have roughly I have this one for five
millimeter and then we're gonna come
into the top view now I wanted to do is
draw a rectangle so I'm going to using
the rectangle Center and type it zero
right there as my center now I want this
one to be square so holding the shift
key will allow you to do a square right
there we want to get it as close as to
the stone
and roughly like this okay once you have
that I want to rotate it for 45 degrees
so I'm using the gumball rotate 45
degree type it there and you will turn
in the orientation for 45 degree all
right now this square is really harsh so
how are we gonna get the shape uh it's
nicer and Smoother by using the command
for rebuild with the rebuild command
you're gonna as soon as you click on it
you're going to see that it's kind of
turning into a really small a small
surface it's more like a star looking
things and that's what we're looking for
so in my point count I set it up for 12
and my degree set it at 4 3 and then we
click OK there all right so the shape is
really close for what I want but I do
want to have this bump right here when
it coming in coming out another bomb so
if I'm moving those two coming out like
that you're gonna notice it I'm losing
that curve right there so in fact I will
need to have more point and let's go
ahead to use a rebuild one more time
instead of a 12 point let's try a 16
point and see what happens as you can
see now I have a one extra point right
there in the middle whatever you're
going to do you have to do the number
that you can divide it by four so let's
try if I try next level for 20 and this
is what we get and let's click OK all
right so now you can see I got one more
control point right here if I'm moving
up those two I'm not going to be
affected uh based on this two and these
two can go lower right so we can get
this type of a shape now I wanted to the
shape to get a little bit nicer instead
of just using my free hand to move them
so first of all I'm going to pick up all
four of them have them coming in a
little bit all right next one I want
those two two coming out but we need to
have a line as a reference so I'm going
to have a line snapping into the zero
holding the shift right here and using
that line I'm going to rotate it from
this point and going up for 45 degree
there and then this will be our
guideline let me Mark this line into the
red colors might be easier for you to
see so when you are moving those two
points and we want to use the move tool
I want to make sure my near point is
check for my all snap and I'm going to
snapping right here and just move it up
with this guy and I'm going to bump it
up even more for 24 we need to have a 1
in the center so let's go
to do 28 there so there will be a one
right in the middle all right so now we
have this I'm going to use the move
command and then we're gonna moving up
like that so that's how we get this pump
right there okay so now we have the
shape that we want and let's go ahead to
and I don't want to do all of them so
let's go ahead to using the split
command I want to split with the point
and that's split into this quadrant and
this quadrant and we can delete the rest
of them all right and then all we need
to do is to
mirror to the other side and have those
two mirrored to the other side as well
all right so now we have this shape
that we want and let's go ahead to join
it now this is going to be inside shape
I'm going to bring in a little bit like
this more close to my pendant all right
so now we have this one let me turning
into the green color we'll need to
figure out the rest now the size of a
stone I'm gonna pick up this Stone and
bring it up here and just size it down
to whatever size that it's going to fit
for it and we're gonna bring one close
to here you're going to have another one
roughly right here so that's making a
copy with the gumball just hit the ALT
key and I wanted to align horizontally
to
zero so then we will have another one
here this is just here for us to take a
look if the stone is a right size if I'm
going to have another one probably will
be right here and then we have a space
in between about right here now it look
okay to me for whatever that we have set
up here you just want to make sure that
you don't want it to have a stone it's
way too far in this case if you're using
a measurement tool you're going to
measure in between roughly here and here
and that gives you a 0.2 millimeter
which is a good size because we need to
have the prong there okay if that looks
okay to you we need to have them to be
more accurate I'm going to draw a line
starting from this point make sure that
I hit the Tab Key and then when I move
it out it will coming out as an
extension right there all right so this
Stone it should be moving
close to this curve whenever how far you
like to have from this point to the
stone you need to move it on this line
so next one I'm just going to bring one
right there and hit the o key and the
same thing I'm going to bring another
one there or you can simply just mirror
within this line here and then you can
bring another one right there okay so
now they look okay let's take a look uh
we want to measure from this point and
up roughly about the same distance to
the edges and knowing that this is
1.32 all right so I'm going to have this
one using the offset tool and I want to
offset
1.32 hit enter and then I'll get this
shape like this
now sometimes you may not like offset
but the benefit is create an equal
distance if you don't like the shape
it's probably because this shape is a
little bit too round let me put another
one right here as a reference if you
offset inside
want to discuss a little bit about this
if you offset inside you're going to see
there's a lot of the sharp point if you
offset outside you're going to see it
getting more rounded there and that is
the nature of the offset with that
saying if you like it to be more sharper
or you want to have more control of the
outside this should be your outside
shape first and then you can offset
inside another thing that you can do is
just making a copy overall smaller that
will work too it's up to you so let me
show you this one if I wanted to just
eyeball it and getting these things a
little bit bigger you're going to see
that I keep the shape better but
unfortunately the coming in different
distance for for example the curve right
here in between from this point to this
point it's 1.38 but from this point to
this point it's 1.58 all right so it
depends on how you lie like your design
in this case I will prefer just offset
so I simply just wanted to have this one
offset my curve and for the equal
distance all right once you are done we
can have this one this one this one and
we want to mirror to the other side
and have this one this one this one this
one and that's mirror to the other side
all right so that's the good arrangement
there now next one we wanted to creating
the prom depends on how you like your
prong and you can see that they are not
the same level that's fine we can pick
up all the stone and then we just need
them to be aligned so that's using a
light horizontal
and we want them to be a line right
there all right so now we have this we
just need to creating the prom let's go
ahead to creating the prompt by drawing
a straight line
and with this straight line let's go
ahead to use the pipe tool and we want
to pipe it about
0.25 here for the radius and then so
we'll get some size like this now within
this size what you can do is you can
using them as a share prong
so let me put it into the top view you
can use them as a Shear prong like this
one and the other one for interior now
the interior you can make them a little
bit smaller if you want to right but I
don't suggest to be too small it might
break as also you are not cutting too
much into the stone so you should be
fine and I'm going to continue to moving
this one you can also not having a Shear
prong just you wanted to have an
individual prompt but prone to be
smaller that will work too all right so
now I have this one and this one
that we arrange and they look nice we
are just going to use the mirror command
and Mirror to the other side and once we
have that let's go ahead to pick up
those not the stone
and we wanted to mirror to the other
side as well okay so after that it's a
bunch of picking
another store I should have a group of
the stone that might make my workflow
faster and then we just need to mirror
to the other side
so now I have all the prongs arranged
don't forget the Big Stone Nick prom 2
and that's why we leave that little
space there so let's go ahead to draw a
straight line and I wanted to pipe it
for a little bit bigger with this Stone
size I may want to do 0.6 in the radius
which is the diameter for 1.2 millimeter
and see if this is too big if it is too
big of the size you might want to size
down to one so let's go ahead to make
them a little bit smaller I think I make
it the space is not big enough all right
so now we have that one there we just
need to Polar array so that's using the
polar arraignment and we wanted to use
the prong snapping into the zero we need
to have four of them so we got something
like this okay now with this uh complete
the stone is actually floating in the
air and it's not too good so that let's
go ahead to creating a under bezel so we
want to use this tube snapping into the
zero and then let's go ahead to disable
the all snap so we don't snap crazy I
you wanted to make sure that on the
bezel is smaller than the stone size all
right and then we just move it down like
this
cool all right so now the next things we
wanted to do is pick up this curve and
this curve and we want to come into the
solid extruded planar straight we only
need one side we don't need both sides
so we want to at least cover the stone
uh cool it so it doesn't showing up
there all right so this is will be what
you like I also have other video talking
about how to cut out a hole in the back
of the stone and if you like you can
make them taper by holding the control
and shift using your gumbo and then you
can pick up the surface right here and
just 3D scale it down so it will be a
little bit taper and you can trim the
button all at once so this one doesn't
stick out after that you can try to cut
out the back of the stone so you will
have a hole behind it and the stone will
look brighter I have other video talking
about that so I don't want to repeat
here to save some video time and this
will be dependent for this star looking
shape I hope you enjoy the video if you
like to know more trick about jewelry
Cat 3D modeling check out my membership
program a small amount monthly fee it's
going to help me as a small YouTuber to
continue making a free video for you and
everybody else thank you for watching
hope to see you in the membership
program
[Music]
foreign